congressman Eric suavo joins us the
Democratic congressman there former
presidential candidate what do you think
of that congressman people who want to
worship tomorrow of any faith and doing
so whether it be a synagogue whether it
be a charge of though they want to do it
what would you advise well first happy
Easter or cogsa Mayock if you're
observing Passover and I'm sorry that
that's not the case I wish I could be a
church tomorrow celebrating Easter as
well but I'm going to follow the
guidelines and I actually the
vice-president a person certainly a
faith is telling church leaders to
observe the CDC guidelines in the sooner
we all observe them the sooner we all
can get back to our houses of worship
Congress even much thought I do want to
get into stimulus because I know that's
what we're here to talk about but to
what would make you comfortable
unwinding some of these stay at home or
shelter-in-place
provisions what would you want to look
for a consultation with others in your
state the governor would have you
because there are a lot of different
factors what would be something that
would say all right
I could see loosening up a bit yeah I've
given a lot of thought to this Neil
because I want to get back to reopening
America as soon as possible and so I
think first and foremost
county-by-county looking at the
hospitalization cases as soon as you
start to see a steady decline where on
Wednesday you had fewer cases and you
did on Tuesday and so on second you know
wider access to diagnostic testing that
can tell us if people have antibodies so
that they are immune I believe that
areas that like the bay area by the way
you know in Alameda County my home
county we have just around 700 cases
that is remarkably low we were the first
a shelter-in-place so we should be able
to shelter out of place very soon but I
think that may mean having travel
restrictions on anything coming to the
Bay Area from places with higher cases
or they're not starting to come down so
just as we face into a shelter in place
I think we can phase out and maybe it's
restaurants being open at half capacity
non-essential workers going back to work
but following physical distancing
guideline but access
to testing wide access not just to
knowing if you have cloven but also if
you had it in the past that would make
me feel comfortable I just think some
areas are gonna come out of it faster
and they're gonna have to protect
against areas that aren't out of it yet
congressman there's been a big battle
between Republicans and Democrats over
this additional 250 billion dollars in
financing that would work to beef up
these small business loans and or grants
and and we've got Chuck Grassley gone a
little earlier serve was saying
Democrats should know that there's going
to be follow-up stimulus and relief now
is not the time to do it with this where
are you on that well I want more relief
to come whether it's 250 billion or more
I think we'll probably need more what
we're saying though right now is that
get the money out the door that we
already voted on you know we spoke with
secretary minuchin on a house Democratic
Hall on Wednesday and he said of the 349
billion to go to small businesses only
96 billion has gone out as of Wednesday
so we're all for you know continuing to
provide relief but we want to get the
money out that's already been promised
and we want to make sure the next
tranche of dollars goes to the areas
that are hardest hit particularly in
minority communities particularly among
you know african-american communities
where we're learning from CDC guidelines
that they have been hit harder by this
so we want to do it right but we want to
get the money that's already been
appropriated out now all right well the
figures up to about under 25 billion
right now so they have contemplated that
demand is such congressman that maybe by
the end of the week after next
all that money will be gone that's why
they're hot to trot to get this
additional money out there because the
demand is overwhelming would you
consider holding it up for any of these
other requests that you're making no in
again it's it's just to make sure that
it's going to the right places that were
not you know it's not giveaways to big
businesses who don't meet it but I look
I talk to small business owners every
single day every single hour actually in
my district I know that they're applying
they're hearing from the banks that the
loans are on hold and they're
the money is not coming through or at
least not as much of it that they need I
want to make sure that as much as our
small businesses need to pay their
employees comes through and I also again
want us to be able to reopen Main Street
as soon as it's feasible
all right Congress well thank you for
taking the time continued good health my
family and your residents